good morning John I've got a question
sitting up here of a little while and
you know I got a lot of questions up
there frankly I'm kind of a question any
kind of a guy but this question has been
sitting up on the brain for years maybe
like six or seven years now so what did
he get it out out of my head in the form
of a song and share it with all of you
it goes like this
Oh JK Rowling what are you doing with
your time you're like giving all your
money to charity and I guess that sounds
just fine but I'm a wondering if you got
just a couple more shots maybe I don't
know you could crack a laptop bow do it
as a favor to me do it for the kids or
do it for charity add to it for the HPA
oh I don't really care just do it today
[Music]
I know that the idea probably stresses
you out
I know that I would feel that way after
making something so damn great for me
would be an inescapable cloud of doubt
but don't let that fear get to you this
is clearly something you can do and the
pressure from people like me does it get
a little old yeah probably but hopefully
you understand why I prize so pick up
your pen Joe do it just give it a try so
oh JK rowling what do you do with your
time and give it all your money to
charity and I guess that sounds just
fine but I'm all underneath a I've just
a couple more shots maybe I don't know
you could crack a laptop oh do it as a
favor to me do it for the kids or do it
for charity at Duke for the HPA oh I
don't really care just do it today
I'm giving you absolute creative freedom
maybe you can ride up a screenplay or
prequel musical for Broadway or
collaborate on a conic with Joss Whedon
or a miniseries for the BBC and ii-if
that sounds good to me I suggest you
avoid cartoons are giving Fox a chance
to cancel you and after considering this
one pretty carefully please don't make
an MMORPG cuz that would totally destroy
my product to 50 so otak rolled and what
do you do for your time
give it all you buddy to charity and I
guess that sounds just fine when I'm why
don't have you got just a couple more
jobs maybe I don't know you can crack
like top hope do it as a favor to me
dude forget to do it fraternity this is
the bottle out of the garbage house
dance a little bit and I'm gonna get on
a plane to see John paternity leave this
is pretty good it's about as good as yes
have you been doing this is this what
you've been doing all time staying up
all night as well but not unlike the fun
teenage way Hank I'll see you on Friday
you'll see me right now I know I haven't
said it in a long time I was feeling I'm
spilling it
good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's my
video I still got how's Alice oh she's
great she's beautiful we love her good
you seem like pretty good parents I'll
be honest we try hard I want to thank
the right there for all their good
wishes and we appreciate it but yeah
we're just really enjoying being a
family of four John you see you right
now all right
and they're just laughed at a joke for
the first time what was he watching
Annoying Orange